die gesundheitsbehörden registrierten am
sonntag in tschechien den neuen
rekordwert von 11.100 neun fällen
innerhalb von 24 stunden
aber die menschen bleiben nicht zuhause
sie gehen auf die straße protestieren
gegen die maßnahmen circa 2.000
demonstranten zählte die polizei erlaubt
waren 500 so viele meiner bekannten
leiden wegen der regierung so viele
leute müssen zu hause bleiben weil sie
kinder haben das ist nicht gut die
tschechische ökonomie wird sterben mehr
als 8000 corona neuinfektionen täglich
das ist das traurige ergebnis einer
womöglich etwas zu locker gehalten denn
corona politik der letzten monate ohne
abstandsregeln und ohne eine masten
pflicht das ergebnis nun die
tschechische republik musst du den
notstand ausrufen und befindet sich in
einem teil doktor und bedeutet unter
anderem cafés restaurants schulen und
bars haben wieder geschlossen und
runtergefahren auf 0 und gegen diese
verwirrenden maßnahmen wollen die
demonstranten hier heute vorgehen unter
anderem dabei fußballfans aus der
hooliganszene die polizei ist alarmiert
und hat kräfte aus dem ganzen land
hinzugezogen
wie die polizei auf twitter mitteilte
wurden 16 von diesen hooligans vorab
wegen der mitnahme von pyrotechnik
schuss und schlagwaffen festgenommen zum
nachmittag wurde die demonstration dann
aufgelöst
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren